[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
nick wright
he's a popular co-host of first things
first on fox sports one and he joins us
on the program
good morning nick how are you hey how
are you guys
i i'm adding to my bucket list go on a
buddy trip with dan patrick i didn't
even know that was available but i'm
adding it
okay but would you go fly fishing
i've never been fly fishing fishing is
something that in my head
i love and then i'm like i've done it
once in 20 years as an adult
so how much do i actually love it but i
think i like it i don't totally
understand what fly fishing is
seems like you're wading in water i
don't get it this is probably not the
best
discussion point here i've just seen it
on
movies yeah like uh a river runs through
it with brad pitt
yeah where they they make it exactly
what i was thinking of yeah they make it
seem romantic and
it's really hard to do but you do feel
like you're actually
fishing like there's skill to it instead
of just i'm going to throw a line out
the water
and then just wait for you know the fish
to take it
i feel like maybe i'm wrong i feel like
maybe in your younger days you were a
big
pay to go on a big excursion you
cast and then you go drink and then
somebody
reels it in and you take the picture no
no that was the damn
no no no never did that no no i did i
didn't want to do any deep sea fishing i
i would just go in lakes and creeks and
go fishing
but no no there was never hey can you
put
the the worm on the hook throw it out
there
catch it and then i'll reel it in and i
get the photo op no i
i didn't do a victory lap like that i'm
still working man that's the way to go
yeah i hope to do that one day i think
it's a sign of success i haven't gotten
there yet all right what's up what's the
one topic this week where you're still
going i don't have answers to this
and i want them oh what an interesting
question
but the it's similar to the last time we
talked
did sean payton bet someone years ago
i can win games with a tight end playing
quarterback
and he is still trying to win that bet
that's the question i have
and listen i understand the taysom hill
fans took a victory lap after his
performance against the falcons which
was decent
and that victory lap i hope they enjoyed
it because against the broncos you saw
more of what i thought you were going to
see and i think the falcons are going to
beat them this week
i don't know if you looked at the point
spread there it's new orleans by
only two and a half which means vegas is
daring you to bet the saints yeah like
how can you not
less than a field goal number one
defensive football last five weeks and
the reason you can't
is because they got an hvac playing
quarterback for him and so i think they
lose this week and if drew brees isn't
back
by the time they play the chiefs in two
weeks they
have to go to jameis because the only
chance you're gonna have in that game is
if you can move the ball up and down the
field and score some points yeah i'm
with you on atlanta i thought that they
would win one of these two matchups
with them it just feels like that's
always been the rivalry it's usually
the team that's not supposed to win you
know actually wins on the road but you
know here it is with atlanta only uh
you know two and a half points and i see
i wonder
does sean payton want to see taysom hill
in a situation where he's down double
digit points not that you want to get
there
but it would tell him an awful lot about
taysom hill
if he's down two touchdowns or ten hey
how does he it's like lamar jackson we
want to see what happens when he gets
into a situation like that
it's a i think it's a great point and i
think while the saints they're pursuing
the one seed they obviously think
and should believe they can win the
super bowl this year so we'll take wins
however they come
but i think part of going to taste them
over jamis was to try to gather
information for next season and for
years moving forward
and so in that regard what happened with
them against the broncos was almost
useless
like you can't take anything away from
that game
other than even those of us that thought
it was really hard playing quarterback
in the nfl
it's evidently harder than we thought
because the poor guy
hinton that was playing i mean he was an
unbelievable high school player
a good college player and he went out
there and looked honestly
not to be rude but it was like a guy
picked out of the stands
and so it just told us how much harder
playing quarterback in this league is
even if we knew it
but you can't take anything away from
that game if you're the saints at all
so now maybe you can learn something in
this falcon
why is it that we look for a story
it may not be there but like to me
patrick mahomes has been the mvp
at least for the last month like i like
no no question
but you know tom brady was there we
kicked him to the curb russell wilson
now the defense playing a little better
the offense not playing as well
aaron rod it feels like it's a two-man
race you know we want to
you know bring in roethlisberger but i
don't know
is he most valuable player uh maybe not
but why is it where we keep going
we're you know we have tentacles it's
like an octopus we got to bring in
somebody here to make this interesting
well it's an odd thing to say because
this is only his third year as a starter
but it feels
similar to me like and you'll remember
this fondly
the carl malone mvp in 1997
in barclays and bart barkley i think
actually had a stronger case like in 97
i think the bulls won
68 games they were but it wasn't the 72
wins and malone had never won one
and so i think mahomes has so clearly
distinguished himself as the very best
player in the league
that it becomes a little boring to talk
about and in fairness
the first five weeks russell wilson was
better first five weeks russell wilson
deserved to be there and people got
really caught up in
he's never gotten an mvp vote which i
think misunderstood how the nfl mvp
voting works
it's not a ballot it's one name so if
you're voting for a guy it means you
think you should win it it's hard to
find a year where russell should have
won it
but at this point it would take in my
opinion a homes meltdown
down the stretch because as great as
rogers has been there is one game this
season
that you can say they lost because of
his poor performance
that's never happened to mahomes in his
entire career and i don't expect to
happen this year
we had dan orlovsky from the mothership
on earlier in the week and he said
travis kelsey the
most valuable non-quarterback in the
league
i don't agree with that i think aaron
donald
should win that award i think aaron
donald i
i think the rams if the rams had ryan
tannehill at quarterback i think they'd
be a super bowl favorite i i think they
are crippled by their quarterback play
but donald is
such an unbelievable player i don't know
if kelsey is more valuable than tyree
kill now kelsey has the opportunity
uh i think he's 70 yards short of
leading the nfl in receiving
no tight end has ever led the nfl in
receiving so he has an opportunity to do
that
his production over the last five years
is just it's it's unprecedented
but i do think you saw in for example
the bucks game
they he started killing them once they
started doubling tyree like okay we've
got to worry about tyrique then
everything's open for kelsey
i just think the chiefs are in such a
beneficial spot because he is clearly
the best tight end in football
and while tyree kill isn't the best
receiver in football
i would argue dan he's the best receiver
to pair with mahomes
like even if deandre hopkins is a better
receiver than tyrique
tyrique fits with mahomes skill set so
well that you have those two guys and
you can't double them both
and it allows them both to be the best
versions of themselves is nick wright
co-host first things first on fox sports
one let me shift it to uh basketball
and i know that we there's always people
in the media are going to spin it
and look at the negative side of lebron
james
and i heard this i think skip bayless
even brought it up
hey you know what he should have taken
less money you want to win championships
you want to be like
jordan but it makes me so much okay
so should lebron have taken i i said
lebron did
take less i mean he's making less money
than like six
other guys john wall makes more than
lebron james so
should he have taken less here's the
problem dan let's say he did that
and i'm not naming names you you you
named skip i didn't see skip say that
i'll take your word for it skip's a
colleague
and i obviously have immense respect for
him but i
what i will say is this if lebron james
had said guys i'm gonna sign for the
minimum
guess what the exact same people
criticizing him for taking the max
would say he's trying to stack the deck
by taking the minimum
this is and you know that to be true
if lebron said i'll take the minimum and
the lakers went out and signed giannis
then it was it would be okay lebron is
running from competition
just like last year it was it was
you know oh lebron wants it too easy by
by adding kawhi now he is supposed to
make it too
easy listen lebron james is the most
underpaid athlete
in american sports i don't think that's
really debatable i know it's an
odd thing to say but it's true and
here's the problem for
the the contingent of people that
dislike lebron
they only have the six rings thing left
and in their heart of hearts they know
we've only got
two maybe three years left to hit that
one because the lakers gonna win again
and then they're at five and then if you
think he's not gonna appeal at least
one more like kareem did late late in
his career as a role player you're nuts
so when lebron finishes with the most
points of all time the third most
assists of all time
13 finals appearances six rings what's
going to happen is
folks are going to say wait this was a
debate and so
like it's nice that lebron has not taken
over
like there was the story that came out
he tried to sign luca to team lebron but
nike kept luca with jordan
i think that was actually a really nice
thing for nike to do
that way in 30 years people know what
michael they're like oh he didn't just
have the shoes he also played basketball
because it's going to be everything else
is going to be lebron's
all maybe even that statue outside the
united states
well maybe you have lebron guarding
jordan outside the united center
oh i like that do you think lebron gets
a statue at staples if they win one more
no oh
i just i you know it's weird how people
and i and i said this yesterday or the
day before like we don't want people to
get into our scrapbooks like don't ruin
our scrapbook like we love kobe and we
love magic and jerry west and
you know the people are true lakers like
lebron to people
i don't think they view him as a true
laker even if he wins another title
um and i don't so i got a statue
yeah but i think they viewed him as more
orphans i know
i know it's but he's beloved
lebron is never going to be beloved shaq
was belo
like people love shaq and they respected
kobe and they loved magic and they
respected kareem
i think they look at lebron is you know
he's in town for a few years
and i don't know can i ask you one other
question even though you're the one
interviewing me
yeah there was all right so there's this
speculation that lebron matched up his
contract length with when his kid
when brownie graduates high school right
yeah and i think it's totally unfair
but we all discuss it anyway because
lebron has alluded to this i think maybe
brownie can make the nba one day
but talking about him as a high school
pro guy if they change the rules it's
super high expectations but let's say
they change the rules
and let's say he is the 50th best
prospect on your board
if it is clear if you draft him lebron
signs with you does he become worth the
number one overall pick
three years from now it's a package deal
you have the number one pick you would
be taking the 50th best prospect
of fringe nba 19 year old but lebron
comes with it no no
no fifth pick not in three years
oh oh in three years because lebron will
at that point only be like the third
best player in the league
i don't know if ronnie can play
like i don't i don't know if he's able
to play i have no idea yeah
i mean he can definitely play yeah is he
is he going to be a guy that can make
the league much less make the league
right out of high school now we're
talking about totally unfair
expectations yeah because
i got three more uh seasons of playoff
basketball for lebron
uh nobody's had this wear and tear you
know kareem you know you had
guys who played a long period of time
but nobody's had the wear and tear that
lebron has had on his body and
in three years i don't know what he's
going to be like uh even if i get his
son
you know i don't want somebody hey come
out and watch lebron play you know
18 minutes i don't want to see that no
and i don't know if lebron will ever
play
i listen i think he's going to be able
to play
until he's 40. but would you rather have
lebron
with his son or lebron against his son
what's a better oh i think lebron
against his son is better
i also would think it would maybe be
better for his son i agree i think that
i think playing on the same team as him
would be
very very it's insane we're talking
about this but
i think it'd be better against him i
think it'd be and by the way if we're
talking about it
you know five years from now and lebron
is playing 20 minutes a game and a
little creaky
his son could have the iverson on jordan
moment except on dad
that would be unbelievable
yeah but i could hear skip bayless yeah
michael jordan never used his sons to
stay in the game
yeah and then you can hear nick wright
say hey you listen michael's sons
weren't good enough to make the league
i kid i mean and i don't kid it's
accurate but i love marcus
this wasn't quite good enough uh have a
good weekend i don't think you created
any negative headlines today
i appreciate that thank you and i am
awaiting the invitation
for the guy trip since you've told fritz
he's out
i do drink i smoke cheap cigars and you
can teach me to fly fish
all right sounds good sounds like a plan
thank you bud
that's uh nick wright co-host of fox
sports first things first